the handwriting of Lucy letby on a
Post-It note found in her home shortly
after her arrest now presented as
evidence the prosecution say she's
guilty of murder
I don't deserve to live she writes
I killed them on purpose because I'm not
good enough to care for them I'm a
horrible evil person then in capital
letters she writes I am evil I did this
Lucy letby's accused of murdering seven
babies and attempting to murder 10 more
over a 12-month period the juries heard
that babies previously in good condition
suffered catastrophic collapses when
Lucy letby was around at the Countess of
Chester Hospital some made remarkable
recoveries when she wasn't the
prosecution say her malign hand was at
work
but the jury then heard for the first
time from the defense for Lucy letby
describing that same posted note not as
a sign of guilt but as the anguished
outpouring of a young woman in fear and
despair at the enormity of what was
being said about her Ben Myers KC
pointed out what was also on the note
she wrote that she would never have
children or marry she wrote of Despair
and that I haven't done anything wrong
Mr Myers told the jury they shouldn't
accept the prosecution's theory of guilt
based on coincidence Lucy letby he said
shouldn't get the blame if she's not
responsible maybe there were others who
made mistakes systems that failed he
said Lucy letby was adamant she'd done
nothing to harm those babies he said the
defense recognized the sadness distress
and anger caused by these allegations
family members of some of those babies
listened in court as he said sympathy
was rightly with them but he urged the
jury not to let emotion take the place
of reason
this trial is expected to last six
months Lucy letby denies all 22 charges
she faces Greg Milam Sky News Manchester